[Music]
what's going on guys fantastic beasts
and where to find them it's just around
the corner and with the news that Johnny
Depp is playing the evil wizard
Grindelwald and that young Dumbledore is
gonna be part of the franchise these new
movies are starting to smell a lot more
like prequels than ever before and that
got us thinking are there any good
prequels and which ones are the worst of
the worst
join me as I count down screen junkies
list of the best and worst prequels of
all time oh and before you ask we did
not count reboots like Batman Begins
Casino Royale new Planet of the Apes new
Star Trek whoa
gotta draw the line somewhere first on
our list of the best prequels of all
time at number five is Fast Five Fast
Five takes place before the Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift you can tell because
the character of Han is not burnt to a
crisp like he was at the end of the
third fast movie which is actually the
sixth fast movie that means that fast
for Fast Five invest six all count as
prequels but everyone knows Fast Five is
the standard-bearer it turned the
franchise into the over-the-top heist
movies that they've become it introduced
the franchise to a baby oil slather
Dwayne the rock Johnson and it featured
Vin Diesel remembering everything about
his father
[Music]
by the way Fast Five inclusion on this
list is the most serious anyone has ever
taken the mythos of The Fast and Furious
franchise
everybody loves Hugh Jackman and there
are a lot of people who would say this
amazingly talented Aussie can do no
wrong those people obviously haven't
seen pan which leads off our worst
prequels ever list although to be fair
very few people in general saw pan this
misguided Peter Pan prequel was a mega
bomb at the domestic box office and goes
down as one of the biggest examples of
why was this movie made in recent
history
maybe Warner Brothers was just pandering
to the extremely niche Nirvana fan
pirate enthusiasts crowd
[Music]
I don't know what I just watched but I
hated it number four on our best list
final destination five this film makes
the list because it's the rarest kind of
prequel the sneak prequel final
destination five makes its own case as
one of the best movies in the franchise
by featuring some of the most elaborate
well choreographed deaths this side of
Rube Goldberg but it scores its final
points by revealing at the end
spoiler alert that the whole movie takes
place before the first final destination
movie you know a lot of people write the
final destination movies off as being
gimmicky lightweight fluff notable only
for inventing creative ways to kill
people and they're right I have no real
defense for liking these movie so much I
just do coming in hot at number four on
our worst list The Hobbit movies now I
have been an outspoken critic of The
Hobbit movies since they came out and I
make no bones about the fact that I find
these films sorely disappointing full of
filler a lot of wandering around
aimlessly and succumbing to gold
sickness
what makes me angry estuve all a really
weird elf dwarf romance subplot that
just went absolutely nowhere Oh number
three on our best list Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom
also known as the movie that scared the
crap out of so many kids they had to
invent a new rating pg-13 a lot of
people who haven't read the IMDB trivia
section about the second Indiana Jones
movie may not realize that it's set in
1935 a year before Raiders of the Lost
Ark thus making it the first Indiana
Jones Adventure save for the young
Indiana Jones chronicles TV show or
whatever and while it's often regarded
as the least of the original three
Indiana Jones movies fans can unite over
the fact that it's not Indiana Jones and
the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull which
ripped our hearts out of our chests in a
completely different way then Temple of
Doom did
number three worst you knew it was
coming the Star Wars prequels
but I'm not talking about the George
Lucas trilogy featuring Jar Jar Binks a
wooden Anakin Skywalker and sand that
gets everywhere no we're not gonna talk
about those I'm gonna talk about the
very first Star Wars prequels the Ewok
movies set between a New Hope and Return
of the Jedi 1984 s caravan of courage
and a walk adventure and 1985's
he walks the battle for Endor gave us
all a preview of the horrors to come I'm
going over that storm get me some more
soup whatever you do you stay right
where you are these are not the prequels
you're looking for the other prequels
aren't either
I hope rogue one is good coming in at
number two with a bullet on our best
list the Godfather Part two one of the
great films of all time one of the great
sequels and one of the great prequels
the only thing that kept this movie out
of the top spot is that it's only half a
prequel in current day we follow Al
Pacino's Michael Corleone II and his
descent into darkness but the heart of
the film is in its flashback scenes as
we follow Robert De Niro's Vito Corleone
II and his ascent into becoming Marlon
Brando fun fact
director Francis Ford Coppola mentored
none other than Star Wars director
George Lucas which means we're all very
lucky that there aren't Godfather
special editions featuring CGI horse
heads and sunny shooting first and then
a Christmas spectacular starring the
Godfather gang I'm gonna make you an
offer you can't refuse to have a Merry
Christmas number two on our worst list
x-men origins Wolverine Wow the jack man
is back twice ending up in the crap pile
on this list and he's answering the
question how do you screw up a Wolverine
origin movie I mean what should have
been a total slam-dunk featuring a fan
favorite superhero became an absolutely
unwatchable mess
featuring answers to questions that fans
never asked an opening credits scene
that was better than the rest of the
whole movie laughably bad CGI adamantium
claws and character killing cameos from
gambit and Deadpool that's right this
movie single-handedly killed gambit an
awesome character who's still struggling
to get a movie off the ground and it
almost buried Deadpool forever were it
not for Ryan Reynolds and is off the
charts charisma
I think Ryan Reynolds got this far on a
superior acting method coming in at
number one topping our best list the
good the bad and the ugly it's crazy to
think that Sergio Leone's classic films
in the man with no name trilogy were
received with mixed critical response
upon their release but it's true
originally criticized for their violence
Leone's spaghetti westerns found much of
their acclaim in later years set prior
to the other films in the trilogy the
good the bad and the ugly
stands above all of them and it's now
considered one of the best movies ever
made the score from Ennio Morricone is
truly iconic the characters are
unforgettable and it currently holds a
spot in IMDb's top 10 movies of all time
Quentin Tarantino even called it the
greatest achievement in the history of
cinema and if Quentin Tarantino says it
you know it's true except for that time
in 2013 when he said The Lone Ranger was
one of the 10 best films of the year
then last year he was a really big fan
of the intern with Robert De Niro and
Anne Hathaway so that was kind of weird
you know what I take back everything I
just said about Quentin Tarantino but
yeah good bad and ugly it's like great
adios and finally we come to the number
one movie on our worst list the top of
the crap pile you know to decide what
movie should hold this vaunted honor we
asked ourselves what movie would I
rather put ice picks into my eyeballs
than watch again and the answer was
unanimous minions that's right your
aunt's favorite Facebook meme is also a
prequel to the despicable Me films and
spoiler alert it's insufferable I don't
know if it's the non-stop gibberish the
chaotic jumble of sub cartoonish action
or the fact that this movie made over 1
billion dollars worldwide
IRA's
sent to you for that minions I would
watch any of the other movies on this
list eight times before I would watch
minions again once do you know how bad a
movie has to be for me to say that I
would watch x-men origins Wolverine
eight times minions fans I'm not saying
you're bad people yeah I'm I'm not
saying you're wrong for loving your
minions but I am saying I don't think I
can be friends with you I apologize but
not not so what to think of our list are
there any good prequels that we left off
where you're like why wasn't that on
there or were there any real stinkers
that we forgot about let us know in the
comments section below
we want to know I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye hey guys
did you know that this end card works
with your phone now I know right click
the boxes below to watch more screen
junkies videos and click the screen
junkies logo to subscribe and get this
show
honest trailers movie fights and more